[music]
as an actor from mandl ladies and
gentlemen that's a fact ballaballa
in january were so different is
integrated and exchange between for
five years been working on writing some pieces
one only from tomorrow noon on
which kennedy was murdered and take
me all the teams president  was successful at the
palace what
you showed the piece with the wild west we have
not progressed a cooperation conception
application that goes over three years and you
the tenants in the west was the first
piece of this conception and guess
which two more projects will follow
and me  should I
focus more on female roles dance tidy
strong women in my pieces
people with disabilities also wanted to give this to
a student council because I
think that the work of people
with disabilities is mostly
worth nothing so I now
that excited about them being
excluded from society  and you are
not allowed to present your work
I think a  people without disabilities
should also work with people with
people and vice versa
people with disabilities should work
together with people without
disabilities so that
everyone can see exactly what they are
doing and what the others are doing and
what should be done  the other
groups in their respective work to
take in
[music]